[Music]
and what the [ __ ] news what the hell
buck submitted by bet greater than a
bear hmm to middle school girls aren't
with knifes plan to kill their classmate
and drink their blood
[Applause]
did you watch the I never thought of the
special about the tailored Skyler nice
girl wear her two best friends killed
her with knives in the woods whoa I
remember that man no that's a different
one but these girls went back to school
like nothing even happened and they were
like all trying out for the play and
like doing a little stuff and there were
her best friends and they were even
crying and being like we'll help find
her and stuff where do they put the body
yeah in the woods buried under some [ __ ]
I live in by the woods or everyone goes
to the woods to drop [ __ ] off I just
want a fish oh it's awesome
that's why when I hike in the woods I
always either tell him or myself and I'm
just like yo I wonder where your bodies
are here I think that whenever I'm in
Griffith Park me too big I'm like I
think that in the Angeles like you know
the road like the Mulholland Drive no
not that what Angeles forest but that
one oh yeah I've never heard of it well
I believe you anyway so these two middle
school girls middle school just 11 and
13 oh these girls gotta go 11 and 12
where do they live
East LA
Central Florida we don't do that type of
[ __ ] no dude it would be employed to
steal your man Florida does some crazy
[ __ ] always Florida yes so they were
planning to kill their classmates so
they were planning on sneaking out in
the bathroom and they wanted to kill at
least one student by slicing their
throat
oh damn that's hella messy and they were
gonna drink it
yeah there's other ways slice it and
stick a straw in the throat I'm cutting
up the victims throat cut up their
bodies innovate the flesh drink their
blood
oh they would have died anyway and then
at the end of that like they were
planning at least one but their goals
their goal was there so goal oriented
for about 15 to 25 students like
classmates updated yeah and then at the
end of it you eat that much they're
gonna commit suicide at the end of that
I mean love that's I'm like how do you
what in what did they have a notebook
full of their plans like we're gonna get
they draw it and [ __ ] we're gonna get
that [ __ ] Rachel because she was
[ __ ] mean if you're 11 you could just
pass that off as a fictional story
you're writing No well they don't
mention anything about writing so it
seems like one of the administrators
overheard their plan in the back and
they found knives in their bags or they
found four knives a pizza cutter and a
knife sharpener Wow pizza cutter like
how are we gonna cut the legs I got a
pizza cutter rolls on a roll like really
hard
imagine they kill people it's sharp in
really well have a sharpener
nice dude they wanted to this to 25
people from 8 a.m. to 3 p.m. because
it's like very 12 and 13 year old like
even their equipment is [ __ ] young
yeah murder mines has the Internet mess
us up so bad they're like oh that's so
cute they had a pizza a while I think
they're dumb I'm like their toilet
brainstorm and this is the funnest thing
they can think of doing fun at all human
flesh they would get sick they came up
with this whole plot after watching
scary movies at one of their houses over
the weekend
this is what they're blaming no fine no
they got their period and they were like
[ __ ] everybody
let's go [ __ ] bleep eat their
classmates though that's too much food
225 people you're gonna eat 25
disgusting yeah what movie did they see
where they're like eating a bunch of
people look like they taste good brings
affordable I can't fire thing yeah
they're gonna cook hibachi girl all your
bathroom is chubby Oh a bocce grill it's
like what you bring to the beach so you
could like cook your food there all
right yeah but no so yeah obviously you
could beat the bocce
so no one was hurt because [ __ ] me 11
to 13 it 12 I said on beginning 11 and
12 but yeah so they caught they got cuts
and now they're obviously gonna be
seeing some therapist you know fighting
jeez what the [ __ ]
like I'm so creeped out if I would take
more dad and I'm like oh I have to sleep
in their house every night I would take
it seriously though because like there
are a lot of cases in Japan of child
killers really guys are so many it kind
of like you know how out here we have
the stairs yeah school shooters out
there um yeah it's just nuts like
they'll like kidnap kids and like keep
them as like what are you gonna have
another kid yeah like junior high kids
sometimes as young is like like 10 11
years old starting like like kidnapping
preschool kids and [ __ ] like yeah
shaking them and burying them it's just
sad [ __ ] like it's crazy
and there's this one case of a boy that
was at home and he was just watching
horror movies non-stop and staying at
home all day and then he started like
wanting to do that yeah and then he
actually got somebody like a little boy
and then like and then you just buried
his body after you killed him and stuff
in the park and then like the forest or
something yeah yeah that's a lot of is a
lot of crazy
yeah we're I'm so glad I just watched
Mike martial arts movies I just want to
do kung fu in the backyard just watch
part two like that's way better
dude what I mean something has to have
happen to you to feel that way because
just movies yeah because we've watched
movies and I'm not here like I want to
drink human blood you know I mean yeah
yeah and they might they need like
attention to or something they like they
just want to get a some type of reaction
but and then to even be like we'll kill
ourselves after like what kids like oh
yeah I'll kill myself after like it'll
be fine like I'll shank myself I realize
like the like how permanent killing
yourself is because there's a lot of
kids that I've been reading about
because like headlines are just so
[ __ ] sad there's a lot of little kids
like killing themselves and like you
just feel like this is better than that
saddest book yeah I know they're like
well maybe they'll final you care they
miss me exactly
that's a lot of kids things like that
yeah when I die and I'm a ghost I'll see
them at the funeral and all like and
he'll find me and they don't feel bad
super dramatic yeah
actually didn't really work back in the
day kind of like I'll kill yourself then
I have six other kids oh I'm not gonna
miss you good point so your generation
like I don't know what when you talk to
older people they're like so busy trying
to like work for the farm and eat that
they're like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about yeah yeah suicides almost
like a first it's like a first world pot
almost yeah maybe it's something that
happens when the world gets
overpopulated you know you have it's
like a part of the biological language
oh that's too much luxury here so then
natural selection but a different way
mm-hmm that's yeah that's next level
thank you great thought Stephen King
have you been King too good no it's true
they have this thing where it's cut like
a they call like a biological group mind
yeah some organisms after like certain
things happen to at least like maybe a
hundred of these organisms they all
evolved in a certain way even though if
they've never interacted with each other
so for example if there's like these
birds or something and they realized
that it was hard killing a certain
insect this species of bird all over the
world will start favoring one genetic
trait it's called like universal
consciousness yeah that's crazy they're
something like group consciousness yeah
yeah we're supposed to be having that as
humans yeah yeah yeah wild now what
would you guys do if it was one of your
kids [ __ ] kill that [ __ ] I
can't really because I've never had like
the good hey I'm never good love that
you have for your cats yeah okay now
it's your child I kill that [ __ ]
I told you okay
you have no choice if he did the work
like if this will kill 25 people and ate
them work one on vacation and I'm gonna
kill this [ __ ] on the side of
the road I'm like you I'm so sorry
skydiving Annie we're gonna forget his
parachute yeah I'm sorry world that I
brought a killer into this world
no dude there's people who literally
like have killer kids like Dexter's yeah
dude Dexter's [ __ ] but Dexter treated
the people like he knew in his mind like
training I don't want to hurt you so
because I love you I'm gonna hug you
like very [ __ ] sociopathic [ __ ] you
know what I mean like I'm supposed to
hug you because I love you you know but
he never truly felt it
so that's trips a ton of people that are
like that yeah there's interviews on
YouTube of killer kids what yeah I want
that's interesting you do
yeah yeah what are these what do they
sound that you should start with animals
and then they move on to but they don't
they just don't connect they don't
really I don't get it but one of the
biggest reasons why people kill is
because they don't feel anything so they
need it for excitement so there's this
one guy named the ice man he killed over
like two 300 people and told her he's a
old man but then he started young 300
p.m. because he worked for the Mafia
because he found something like a very
passionate job yeah so he was assassin
that last you what you're passionate
about yeah okay but then he was it was
so interesting like when they we talked
about his kids he was like no he's like
I would never kill my kids I would kill
everybody for my kids you know I even
kill my own wife for my kids well no
it's like for some reason they're like
because they're talking about like who
would you kill who wouldn't kill who's
off-limits or whatever it means I'll
kill everybody go see you and your kids
no no it's like my kids I'll never kill
but it is still married like obviously
because a lot of times these people make
you think that they're normal because
they know how to act between like a
social setting like Charles Manson i
watch hella documentaries on this there
was this guy i forgot who he was but he
was like a gay dude and he didn't like
that about himself and he was a really
good-looking dude so he would go to gay
bars bring dudes home smash whatever and
man [ __ ] kill them yeah or he would
like steal smash even after they were
there so yeah you have a strong libido
cuz after I smash any thoughts of
killing I'm just gonna go to sleep too
but he was ashamed of that but his
[ __ ] fired him up and then he killed
some buddies like you're so gay you made
me gay that's what they're claiming
about the you're whole' shooter to
Florida right it was like a gay
terrorist that's what they were yeah
that sucks man was a terrorist after he
ejaculated
no so like he was gay he didn't like
that about himself and then like she
went to a show
but did you come before you do where's
there was no coming involved okay no
talking about this the guy sounds just
like because you're like oh it's just
like them sama oh so he's a country like
Haiti oh I thought I thought you maybe
you knew someone else with a special
power that can come and do violence I
think he just wanted bus nuts
no thinking about coming now no I can't
do that
I already did I can't come and then do
violence me neither that's it's a
special power there's less war in places
where all the guys are getting late i
think yo it's like why would you want to
shoot people when you're too busy
the testosterone got altered a i'm going
to war that's true
[Music]